it was a
dream and just as disis foresaw the end
of valyria Egon forsaw the end of the
world of
men just to begin with a terrible
winter in the very first episode of f of
the Dragon viseris Targaryen may have
confirmed a decade old Theory believed
by many Game of Thrones and A Song of
Ice and Fire fans for years many Game of
Thrones and A Song of Ice and Fire fans
have believed that the M King Aries
Argan knew about the White Walker threat
Beyond the Wall not only that but there
are many fans who also believe the
reason why the Mad King's last words
were burned them all is because he was
warning everyone about that threat would
it actually be that shocking if George R
Martin later revealed we were all wrong
about the Mad King from the very
beginning in this video I will go over
why I think House of the Dragon may have
assisted in confirming that theory in
that very first episode of House of the
Dragon we learned that House Targaryen
has known about the White Walker threat
ever since aegon the Conqueror arrived
in Westeros roughly 300 years before the
events in a Game of Thrones in that
episode we see viseras inform rira of
aegon's dream of A Song of Ice and Fire
now according to viseris aegon had a
dream that revealed what would
eventually happen to Westeros he said it
would begin with an awful winter gusting
out of the distant North aegon had seen
absolute Darkness riding on those winds
and whatever dwells within will
Slaughter the living after aegon had
awoken from that dream he knew every
Targaryen King who came after him would
need to be ready for whenever this great
winter should arrive that's why we see
viseris giving this information to rira
right before he's about to name her as
his air to the Iron Throne rira would
now have to make sure this same
information is given to whoever succeeds
her that way they can band everyone
together to fight against that great
threat that lies out Beyond the Wall
well the Mad King might have known about
this as well and there's more than one
way he could have found out about the
white walkers now before I reveal how
this might have happened I have to let
all of you know about this amazing new
offer I'd like to thank the sponsor of
today's video brilliant now
brilliant.org is an Interactive Learning
tool that uses a Hands-On approach to
teach you a wide range of stem Concepts
like math and computer science brillian
has thousands of lessons with new ones
being added every month you can exercise
your brain and reach your goals with
everything from foundational and
advanced math to neural networks data
science Ai and so much more AI chat Bots
and quantum computers are Advan dancing
and playing bigger roles in our lives
all the time and learning how they work
is fascinating it has been perfect for
me as a Hands-On learner because it
tests you along the way by offering
simulations to manipulate and quizzes to
further your understanding right now you
can try it for free for 30 days by
visiting brilliant.org talking Thrones
or clicking on the link in the
description brilliant is the best way to
learn something new every day and
learning a little every day can have a
huge impact on your brain's Health and
Longevity I like to spend 30 minutes on
brilliant in the morning while having my
coffee it's a much better way to
stimulate my brain and get ready for the
day than scrolling through social media
now the best part is you don't have to
spend a fortune or four years in a
classroom either like I said go to
brilliant.org Talking Thrones or click
the link in the description to check out
all brilliant has to offer it is free
for 30 days and the first 200 of you
will get 20% off brilliant's annual
premium subscription you don't want to
miss out on this amazing offer once
again I have to thank brilliant for
sponsoring today's video
all right now the first way the Mad King
could have found out about the white
walkers is rather obvious like I stated
at the beginning of this video House of
the dragon's first episode confirmed how
stargaryen has known about them for
roughly 300 years since aegon arrived in
Westeros we saw viseris give that
information to rira then we even saw
rira give the same information to Damon
at the end of the season for all we know
aegon's Revelations about the white
walkers could have went down the line
until the Mad King was made aware of
that that threat even if the Mad King
wasn't given that information verbally
maybe someone had eventually written it
down for him to find that secret was
engraved into the Valyrian steel dagger
after all what if the Mad King found out
about the white walkers as soon as he
became king and the fear of their
arrival drove him mad maybe that fear
made him have some sort of psychotic
break imagine how frightening it would
be if you knew there were these inhuman
monsters out Beyond the Wall who want to
ride south on the Winds of Winter to
wipe out all of humanity remember the
Ranger from the knights watch in the
very first episode of Game of Thrones he
started to seem a little mad himself
after he saw the white walkers first
handers White Walkers I saw
them in fact even Ned Stark said he was
a Madman for believing in the white
walkers the madman sees what he
sees the only major difference is that
mad king wasn't mentioning the white
walkers by name instead his last words
were burned them all in fact according
to Jamie Lannister he said this over and
over again for hours until we finally
stabbed
him he said the same thing he'd been
saying for
hours burn them
all now most fans assume he was
referring to everyone in King's Landing
he even had Wildfire stashed underneath
the city what if he actually did this
out of fear of everyone becoming
soldiers for the night King's Army now I
know this isn't as likely as the first
scenario but you got to admit it's far
more fascinating another way the Mad
King may have known about the white
walkers is from Bran or the three- out
Raven you have to remember the three-
out Raven has been watching everyone and
everything for many many years what if
one of the Targaryen Kings died before
they were able to let anyone else know
about aon's dream of A Song of Ice and
Fire well the three out Raven would know
that and maybe he began to whisper in
the Mad King's ear informing him of the
White Walker threat the real Three out
Raven from the assang of Ice and Fire
novels is a Targaryen bastard which
would make him related to the Mad King
that relation in and of itself may have
led him to warning the Mad King imagine
if he was whispering burn them all into
the Mad King's ear or affecting his
dreams like he did with bran and jojan I
could easily see that driving someone
mad now we would know what those
whispers are but to the Mad King it may
have just sounded like voices in his
head and another option would be bran we
actually saw how this could have been
done through many of Bran's scenes Game
of Thrones when bran was inside the
three-eyed Raven's cave learning how to
see through the were Woods we saw him
shout out to his father during a
flashback
scene
father not only did he yell out to Ned
but it seemed as if Ned heard him he
heard a voice say his name but he did
not know what it was well that same
thing could have happened to the Mad
King only the Mad King began to shout
back what he heard which was burned them
all remember jimie said he was shouting
it for hours I can't help but be
reminded of what we saw happen to Hodor
when he heard mea say hold the door when
Hodor heard that during the flashback
scene it affected him and fried his
brain and all he could do then was shout
back over and over
again now imagine if bran and the 3ad
Raven affected the Mad King the same way
brand and Mera did the Hodor that
Madness might have been brought on by
Bran's desperate attempt at stopping the
White Walkers and the night King what I
also find very interesting is what bran
saw right after Hodor was left holding
that door moments after bran flees from
the threey Ravens cave he begins to have
flashbacks again now during those
flashbacks he actually hears and sees
the Mad King while also seeing images of
the night king and the white walkers
mashed together bur them all where's my
sister
[Applause]
as bran is hearing in seeing the Mad
King say burn them all he's also being
shown flashes of wildfire the night King
and his army everything was in fragments
as it's always been before and that may
have been a glimpse of what he shown to
the Mad King when he told him to burn
them all like I said at the beginning of
the video what if everyone has been
wrong about the Mad King he might have
been giving everyone a final warning
right before he died but history will
remember him as a Madman the same way
Ned saw the man from the Nights Watch
who was only fleeing South so he could
warn everyone
again
[Music]